everybody I'm the executive editor of TV
Guide magazine and we are the folks
behind today's community reborn panel I
assume all of you are beyond being spots
the exit is right over there but thanks
everyone for coming and celebrated
season six community so leave their
rated on number two Community College my
Greendale Community College comm by the
way and we've got a great panel for you
so let's bring up to bring him up on
stage waving her stuff he's okay first
up these are two of them dibi beams
happened to created the world's first
cat powered car the man known as star
burns brighter an actor Dino
stamatopoulos
[Music]
damnit I'm a cop
[Laughter]
thank you for your not
[Music]
[Applause]
he also thinks Donald Sutherland is
hotter than Elliott Gould is executive
producer Chris McKenna
he's the man adult in the ass crack
bandit truly against the executive
producer and creator of community
that's a girl a small-town decal to Jim
Rice
she just like they train words are her
weapons he's breathe out achillea Jacob
finally he loves Scotch themselves and
tolerates Greendale Jeff Winger himself
[Applause]
[Music]
first up please tweet community lives on
or community my son whichever you prefer
thank you to community fans with helping
resurrect the show Yahoo is a very
delicious surprise I'll tell you about
later but don't worry it is not here's
his sperm so the show is back thank
goodness because otherwise it was Canada
big seven and that's Lloyd was going to
come and destroy the world we're safe
move back so damn you're quoted in the
press release you said rest easy Big
Bang Theory look out bang but it's by
the way congrats on getting the worst
bang bus into a major press release sort
of I don't know I I don't have Joel got
my job back season five I looked like
really bad Russell Crowe
[Music]
watching yourself speak click in a world
that's just made of dinosaurs and carbs
Society
[Laughter]
[Music]
giant corporations their tentacles reach
pretty crevices literally I don't know
what goes on I know that the three hours
before the deadline was up we were in
school do you really want to do this I
think I think it first I said no and
then an hour and a half later it was
like I ready because you called me and
they seemed really smart and cool and
then I thought well it doesn't really
matter like where you're doing this I
cannot be the one to not do this so
[Music]
wherever this show is people will find
it especially it wasn't an easy athlete
yeah whoo screams which is a cross
platform you can get on the desktop or
your iOS device or
get this on my desk [ __ ]
Wow with a click of my finger
for this episode of community its season
six of communion
you'll be watching it the way you've
always watched it only now it's legal
[Applause]
kind of temperature enthusiasm you're
wrong I guess you didn't want me to have
their heart broken twice but you were
always sort of whether or not this was
gonna return or not you see me you see
toward you seemed you didn't want to get
your hopes up too much do you want to
get the fan toast if I didn't want them
to be crushed yes I didn't feel like
this was possible so I didn't want them
it was about corporate politics at a
certain point it doesn't it's the
commodity so you demonstrated it's been
overly demonstrated and then it's time
to sit back and see if they can make
something happen
I didn't know they couldn't I didn't
think they could but they did enjoy what
you you always you know you were excited
about bringing the show back
you've always been sort of the wing
leader and then do it first off bring it
back there but also cheerleading the
return of the show and did you ever have
any doubts know who's gonna be back for
Season six I think I can answer that
first of all I'm going to be some of
these at the back all the way at the
back exit these are I'm making a graphic
novel and it's it's a musical so you
know you could download a song and Scott
Adsit from TV's so some tool yes what
were your feelings and sort of you are
broken over the NBC cancellation but did
you ever have any doubt that it would
return somewhere so
[Applause]
because no much like well like a I don't
know a Japanese general of World War two
there was all the only option was
victory or suicide so I love the show I
love the way dad looks all the time any
show of Beyond for as long as it has is
a hard thing and then for the show to be
as good as it is I believe because it is
the greatest television sure when it
[Applause]
and Hawaii I always wanted it I'd wanted
it back if they would pay me what Jim
Parsons is making said is that you if
you had to do it at the Pasadena
Playhouse you would still be doing
community you love this show I would do
it no I was ready to do a regional
theater version of the show definitely
been less time to make it but I could
not be happier the show is back and I
know that all of you mostly white people
you tell people you don't you don't run
them home we go
[Music]
you watch it the way that those people
do which is on tiny little screens and
so and [ __ ] you network television so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
did you how did you guys find out and
punch in reactor to find out you have
another job you're coming back
[Laughter]
we keep killing you know what way to
keep you betcha for I would say we can't
hear
[Laughter]
you know I think that I definitely shed
a tear the date of your canceled
I cried in my car and you know I didn't
want to let go of the show because I
think there are a few times in your life
so you get to work on something that is
as good and funny and groundbreaking and
heart warming is the show so I didn't
want it to end with the show it was hard
to like to pack up and even revisit to
go back go packs like paramount and see
the whole thing gone you know between
that time where they just sort of like
literally stepped out the door so it's
you know it's it's been a blessing each
season to go to the next one and to go
to fix and maybe see that hashtag come
to reality is a wonderful thing
we'll see about that is all hey Chris
person you kind of freaked out people
for a moment you you want Twitter or a
sort of we're we're a little blooming
yeah yeah don't think anyone follows me
in that I tweeted someone like it's dead
move on
[Music]
and I realized people actually pay
attention to my my me waking up you know
with the start going on so it's over and
then tweeting my pessimism but you know
I learned a long time ago I think I was
the Pollyanna of cv3 where you got
ripped off the schedule of you know
people went into their dark hole sounds
like that was like and it's like I'm
such a fool like don't like to you to
openly be that guy maybe I was the guy
who brought it back by saying its back
so you wanna tell us a little bit about
let me know what Ken wavers better
expect on season six I mean have you
started to hiring writers yet I know you
guys have kind of staged what so how's
the process going so far well we already
episode
meowmeowbeenz prequel this is really
gonna take it to prequels guys makes in
share with leather Tokugawa said I'm
sorry
I have no idea I'd start to see its turn
every season this way I know I swear to
god I'm not
no no silliness but I really think that
13 episodes of a show about the faculty
and student body the community college
that's trying to stay above water would
be a great show both appreciated I don't
have any big big highfalutin plans just
a lot just make something out are the
shackles off of me nominated on my
broadcast network you've already
experienced so much on the show through
the years is there anything that you
couldn't do before that you feel like
now you can tie vaccination messaging I
always wanted to get into the show
[Music]
people were resistant to it because it's
not a YouTube or whatever it's on there
we can just do anything it's a question
of is the show gonna be different
because it's a lot to be different how
different is it gonna be I think that
the community that these guys recognize
needs to be they're very careful about
that
my philosophy is attempt to make the
same show and let the lack of boundaries
kind of just make themselves felt
instead of actually 49 minutes long and
say the efforts of all time
it's just look I was just goodbye yeah I
think that the you know a sonnet feels
like a Sai just compared to show you
something
[Applause]
haiku a livery a paint chasing a rhythm
in a structure to them and a sitcom is
around 20 minutes long and a half and
therefore has the certain feel to it
that I definitely don't want to take the
take the wheels up so much - people are
like well this is just some new shadow
well the plan is also to continue to
release the show weekly so it's not
going to be like that flakes all over
the show like they always watched it
yeah it's gonna be weekly the way you
guys watch community I mean a little bit
all it'll start airing and then you'll
turn into you know talk about it for a
week like leave and talk about it and
and then the middle it'll air that's the
way TV yous gonna keep on working first
breed em was saved
subway is out of the picture but its
retail everyone really say is there
anything you can say about that I think
it's I think it's hanging in there
campus I don't know why
but you know from the school where it
tells you that he hates your school and
he doesn't want it to exist and you can
just tell him about so probably it's not
really very realistic there might be
some repercussions
[Music]
they might have to catch it in the
chains diamond teeth yeah those are
sweet diamond - and what about Jeff and
Britta I can they ended things at the
end of last season it seemed like things
weren't moving forward but is there a
future for projectlibre or is it more
Wiener
[Applause]
what do you think you didn't show up
I don't know what's punishment what's
the award for her
that's how I they said all my decisions
I you know I've always said like
community is an ensemble so part of who
headed to that's also a bunch of human
beings human beings fall in love human
beings have crushes human beings are
sexual beings romantic beings which
always complicates life within a family
at your forefront especially a family
and top
[Music]
it's very complicated yeah the and you
know that's the most important day it's
it's not necessarily just a workplace
comedy so centering the show on a
relationship it would would to meet me
the beginning of the end however there
are when it comes to matters of love on
screen
I think the theme come there's an
organic energy takes place you feel the
audience and you you feel the writers
room in you you let these stories happen
Jeff the Britta you know they called
their marriage off at the end of last
episode of their childish people that
we're gonna get married because they
thought the show is over I'm not sure if
not over so we will see what happens and
everyone's gonna be a vampire
where did the good and what what is
wingers state of mind at this point I
mean if he had it does an interesting
season that ended on a high note and
helping save Greendale is is well he
just always be this sort of tortured
person space guy I don't know I mean
Danny put invent that he's pretty
immature and he's like a mom and there's
a light and then he'll go to it and then
he'll say maybe I shouldn't go to it so
it's one of those things where with
Danny right this bag would never presume
to know what Jeff's gonna do why I maybe
grow a tail I don't know but that's why
when we open up dating scripts it's like
opening up Christmas presents so I know
and I'm not gonna guess they doing that
Britain had an interesting year to is
she's matured a bit she's not pretty in
it quite as much like the direction
she's going yes I think she had some
victories this year that were on purpose
which was
[Music]
they actually helped Chavan I was right
in the lava episode about them not
dealing with Tory's departure thank you
[Music]
yes she was also victorious for a moment
in the mustard face merry ambiance
episode
I don't think that she'll ever be you
know not the butt of the jokes in the
group but I enjoyed having different
moments where she was right or actually
a mystery yeah you'll never not be the
worst yes I just want to give you an
update live live tweeting from our
entertainment journalist HuffPost TV
long monologue by Dan Herman about
complexity immaturity of characters and
everyone's a vampire the deep you
weren't quite as many concerts the
season but of course people want to pay
day
of course after the breakup the rap
because if there's one thing I'll ever
see more than season six its gangsta rap
front even though yeah I'm really
dropped it that day
it's just a hidden town now the I am
remember getting that at table even sort
of a little warning that's like a rap no
and then they do over snow but she knew
about version of it but I don't know if
I've ever been more terrified shooting
something because it was wonderful on
the page you also want to be good at
math just saying like yeah you shouldn't
know it it's very it's coming through
bees
you know as soon as I not giving it than
the flop sweat starts and you're also in
this suit it is not forgiving or a rap
artists get it right
okay you know but it was it was a blast
to do and you spat on Gillian and I
alive looking fellow rap artists like me
now
when you move you just can't control
that kind of thing because that's real
more about rap right next to
but anyway I think on some of the
costumes it was refreshing I think you
know sees before there was a lot of
costumes but I think you know last show
is about and this is what I love about
not you know it's hard to answer the
question like what you see them doing
this year you know will they'll be more
of this and more of that but these
characters have a ball from the very
beginning and so they stay true to who
they are yeah dan and the writers have
given them stings to learn it's just
it's like where this sort of has evolved
from the beginning and so I feel like
even with the costumes it is nice to
then see the other side of it which is
also people want to see me unflattering
colors and large short sleeve shirts and
[Applause]
[Laughter]
please make it gold and dirt bring those
colors
[Applause]
misunderstood what traits do you
appreciate our advisor about the demon
about the deed I think he I think if
it's Cory's trying to do his best
I think he's fallen in love with this
place maybe Sian people to a degree that
might be
[Music]
he was a guy who community at his core
really does love these people they and
there's nothing better than deny than
one of those flashback episodes that
talk about the d of coming in there and
announcing the fire just about school
and by the way the schools on fires
essence if I'm a really good guy you and
my best friends oh by the way the money
word I have a couple questions from
Twitter actually throw out there yeah
yeah 92 92 okay go ahead
which week's cast members are coming
back and the Pierces Cherokee Phillip
this year which characters are coming
back Philip Johnson is not to be trying
to happen will there be
another creepy old dude I thought we
have to I want to sit down with the
writers and really talk to her about
that stuff so sorry I can't I can't give
it any sneaky-sneaky keys about that
it's been a big comeback TV shows but I
think it's I think it's contractually
impossible for Tyler to come back would
you guys like tell Oliver to come back
we're not gonna turn away from this
amazing HBO shows HBO shows yeah
favorite question I've got a Twitter's
you don't actually have to answer it but
someone act fan of Abed wanted to know
please ask the whole cast one at a time
which flavour would they choose to be
but please don't ask the apartments
[Music]
because they can already tell I'm bacon
[Applause]
steak wants to know do you feel the show
and move away from Greendale or have to
become its own character I think he's
definitely one away from Greendale
[Laughter]
about more than just that school the you
know going away for season 4 than having
to come to come back and kind of reboot
the show so much so there was a return
of DMD start with Joel well working with
mix for weeks I Googler Google he was
cooler and I could not stop laughing and
really and he was then to the point
where I had to run out of tapes it
looked like I was gonna vomit or sneeze
and so working with him was and then
Chris Elliott who was incredible
[Applause]
murders gets the season Walton Goggins
he was
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah how about your favorite moment from
season five gosh no I was really proud
of season five I was so excited to have
Dan come back and do what I thought was
some of our best work ever
so I don't know it's really hard to pick
an episode given the plethora a
wonderful episode you see all the facts
departure which was you know fantastic
emotional I'll just give you an answer
you really love yeah
[Music]
a quick video I like screaming floor
[ __ ]
- Joel and I like how long it took for
me to watch those girls out of my hair
if they never ever know you shoot yeah
yeah that was an excellent episode Danny
Donald in that enormous bubble banks and
so they had to beat the guy red net put
white powder on him and he was driving
me around on that souped-up library card
safe from the episode and it was just
you know it was amusing I feel like I
drove into going and you kind of killed
it but
you guys need
thank you speaking but uh why I enjoyed
particularly like the DD episode just
because I wasn't part of the first one
in it was really one of those things
where you could find with everyone in
one space and while some people rather
like that but it was so much fun to be
in that bedroom and you were sort of
split up with interesting partners that
you don't normally get to be scenes with
and of course being able to impale
myself at the space knife that all day
[Music]
[Music]
busting into the wall he says do you
think the news financial degrees or
higher about the blueprint
and they got a dick Jonathan got a dough
it was like that I was black
[Music]
proceeded to have the biggest laugh on
the next one
for he was looking down the barrel the
computer is completely on his emotions
the first day on set that Jennifer banks
was there he did that lead to the scene
ran through
to him to give him an adjustment and he
and he said I'm gonna watch you with the
heart
that's inside the body
like you did that long as I explore the
gods sit down and watch you may have
been see this forked into the show it
watching it will say watching Jonathan
work was pretty made I mean he he is
such a good actor what I always just
sort of question myself watching him do
this is what was a great character that
sort of came out of out of nowhere to be
added to this image which is a hard
thing to do but but fantastic fantastic
my favorite party season finders that we
got dude not one not two but three
characters doing Gary Oldman from the
professional
we've looked into getting another
pointer to come on the show these things
were like he won't even entertain any
day and let them fly six figures come in
and then do the opposite everything was
the Dean trying to get his attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Adeena I love that Starbucks always have
David to have Dave Matthews bang at the
ready for those happy moments others
boombox yeah I ever heard the big
Matthews Band before
[Music]
this is hilarious
that was a gold mine the old stables
because our department and today and
everyone's amazing but they had a
blueprint of that car with the skeletal
[Applause]
[Music]
basically
Oh quickly start curtains coming up
would it like at this crazy Akbar they I
never look at that then I did at that
point you need to calm down
[Music]
fizzled it and now you want it back
[Applause]
Wow
now I completely forgot I can tell you
guys this great recipe
season five
[Laughter]
[Music]
you need to clue your
for a good product at ten minutes
Gilligan different that you have to lick
every one of these so these guys define
alright so you know I would love to see
more you know I'd like Troy's departure
episode I would love to see more
[Music]
[Applause]
you're out of time now come up and say
what you're going to say
but we guys store mine up it's overkill
right
wait Michael yes sir and your sport coat
with your t-shirt
[Music]
I was just gonna say that I really
enjoyed Dino knows our goddess costume
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I actually wants to make sure
that what is the state of joy right now
last we saw he was kidnapped by pirates
apparently the harbor maybe ask a baby's
death row Kickstarter to save Troyer's
which I think he put the Bowery in
Brooklyn headlining tonight so Theresa
we just okay it's right choice out there
somewhere he may be a peril
that's that's what movies are made of
[Applause]
I'm coming back Chrissy yeah
Donald's up here listening I'd like to
cut away to Donald eating the barber two
years ago I stole a loan to come up here
and ask you guys a question
I'll go west in the back about the bar
and Donald being that lovara Perrin got
away from those Pyrex around Kickstarter
guys - answered that so can we have like
a real one invites the deputy if only we
were supported by some sort of large
internet science resources to make
something so guys have been working on
that right now look at Kim Kardashian's
gonna make five million dollars off her
game
[Applause]
well we did five seasons with our studio
literally makes computers but all kinds
of cool possibilities we do episodes
like that they got money indeed next
time
hi I'm Sarah I wanted to know if you
guys planned on doing how many new
Christmas episodes they were always my
favorite this new world where it's going
to be on the internet and kind of rolled
out week by week I don't know yeah we're
so far when they're going to be
streaming
some think it's going to be in time we
would like it to be we don't want to be
doing Halloween episode of this in
February about that so yeah no it's the
hope of a better idea of what the would
be actually screams definitely our
schedule what are we calling it five
next up
dr. mall taste of success has psychology
do you think we'll ever see her being a
practicing psychologist
I think she's many years from a degree
and she has to find a clinic that would
hire our patients that would accept her
as their therapist do some good work in
truck work she's doing though you know
maybe she could become an animal
[Music]
you know the possibilities are truly
limited Jim loved the descendants and
way way back on I never had any idea
what to expect
could be a dystopia Horror Show musical
animated series so how do you make sure
that it's a consistent character arc and
narrative throughout the whole show just
more about we consider it really
important to do that we know that if the
show is going to go off the rails
aesthetically that the most important
thing is to have some kind of continuity
of emotion motivation you know Annie
would never say that no matter how funny
we think that is in the right
Gaming would you say that she would you
do that I don't know how we do it my
friends
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are we sure we're not during the show
for Amazon because there's a couple
packages that just yet
what it's like when i'ma go to the
bathroom
[Applause]
I hope
you're right
if they're both human beings they're
they're all the same and that they're
all don't get rid of them a lady this is
the one part of the day where it's not
awkward for them
the target
all right can you talk give it a good
talk okay what's your question my
question is I know that there's not
gonna be like I'm telling this year so
are we going to be seeing the return of
City College underneath it's reversible
he's dead full the rest of the day to
grow in its place that's correct
just keeping you on ahead
what we're gonna do with his oldest are
Virgil's character in charge when you
carats of diamonds to keep my baby
[Music]
[Music]
we dance we only have two hours left so
all right Joe honey stick your hair up
like that or is it just natural
[Applause]
you're asking me look at you it looks
like in the plan of the Apes and cut the
place off
I wish I had there like that if I have
to use the Chris Hardwick cuz I'm going
ball that have to push everything around
and it's like oh I just woke up no he's
balding yeah we going
which takes about six hours yeah it
looks great
[Applause]
so you're in a network that's probably
gonna give you more money
are we finally getting merch like toys
because I agreed any toys please do sing
with your throat
[Music]
[Applause]
she wanted if she is requesting the
weird sound that my throat now makes
which I demonstrated hairy time so those
are the lists of it myself
something is happening in my trachea
this could be our last season game so
better than merch did she just take you
home do you know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
fairness
[Music]
while the toilet came the kettle
[Applause]
but first I'm going to say thanks for
all the laughs you've given us and
[Applause]
and congrats on being resurrected and I
guess my questions for the producers the
writers the creators why Colorado and
we're in the middle do the same thing on
your site you know where they were
remember better not find anywhere why do
i specify where you are but then we're
to think about producing TV is that the
legal team needs you to tell time where
the show is they need a state so that if
you name the character Jimmy Johnson
they have to be able to say well there's
a bunch of Jim Jackson's in collar
there's a bunch of them then they can't
sue us if there's only one that we can't
do it at all is crap so every time you
show a license plate or a driver's
license and get it it's a step so it is
Colorado because flying season one so
here because you would think that into a
location so you in season one all the
tree all the palm trees of paramount
were wrapped in herb they look like fir
trees and then season two that just
didn't bother you know
[Music]
but now that is illegal that is really
awesome statement I think people need to
be aware that the climate is changing
[Music]
believe me save money airbrushing out
pensees and at the same time we're we're
on a North Sea
between that in the backseat you're
doing a really political next season
yeah that's what we should do yeah if
you could choose one movie or TV show
the spoof that you guys haven't already
done what would you choose in what take
your inception erasure of Dobie Gillis
we're doing in function
suggestion 40 what about a crossover
with Ricky Morty Wow Dan you have a lot
of moms out there
as we ponder that thanks sex question
all right
hey question for the actors have some
hope yes transitioning from network to
internet actors because of the more
shenanigans you know along ago rap yeah
acting you have to project more this is
my TV boys
[Music]
look like from driving
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I don't think anything you know can
you still be community whether whatever
I mean she might make some choices we
don't get you know I'm saying like she
might make some choices as an actress
that will be like you know Joel might
make some choices choices really what so
on the computer screen if I be about the
same thing right you like I mean I think
a lot of people will see the screen and
go oh hey Moby has a new video Steven
Soderbergh's talking
and none of you have a no nudity clause
right so sky's the limit no nudity
clause
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you get that Microsoft tattoo
- we've shown everything everything is
there any chance that you can have a
character from the suit
more specifically mankini
[Applause]
he works at the e Network which
everybody knows just a paid incredibly
well there so I know if you see watched
by emmy-nominated five so
[Applause]
or the Big Brother ripoff show that we
show so it's really really I don't know
if we can afford it I'll let him know
that he said it was very nice give to
rippity all right before we get to the
next question I got one more
housekeeping for everyone Yahoo wants
you know that fans can watch on Yahoo
screen or by downloading the free Yahoo
screen app for iOS Android Roku Apple TV
and Xbox 360 production starts later
this summer as soon as episodes are
ready to get to a dead Yahoo will
release them weekly it's exclusive to
Yahoo and also the community season 5
DVD will be released on August 5 so pick
that up
and Michael family you guys are the
greatest fans in the history of all time
[Applause]
response of god bless giving away free
subway sandy
to aid in so subway is I may have lost
its chance at purchasing Greendale but
it still feed all you guys so Yahoo
screen is celebrating the recent
resurrection of community by providing
fans with free Subway sandwiches here at
Comic Con 4 p.m. to 8 p.m. today go to
the subway at 611 K Street downtown San
Diego free sandwiches for 4 hours there
all I think that actually paid to
different characters as well so you can
actually order a burrito on the upper
level the convention centers so you'll
see all these guys one more time
of course be able to look out for season
6 of community then we start writing any
fall so probably more like sometime
after Christmas okay after Christmas
guys
demo that happened
to see the chain go we see the chain
people like that guy
[Applause]
community lives on Yahoo
[Applause]
you